yeah welcome to new video against I led
in here on the 92 talaash yeah there
many lines I played a six off net
tournament chess this is often a good
move for c5 Bishop d3 probably see 5
yeah well the normal move would be eat
XD 5 the screen txt five so terrible and
one a six is another perfect move ok
let's take with the pawn it should be a
decent isolated Queen support position
he's gotta and wrong the P the bishop on
d through is just a d3 is just on the
wrong square needs to be on e2 in this
position it's not a big deal but it is
some it is a positive thing in my favor
that the bishop is misplaced 83 okay
yeah Bishop g4 he was probably worried
about so can I go here
I didn't really think about this that he
played rookie one also to prepare the
bishop booth yeah this was a bit silly
okay yeah it's a bit annoying to have
this Bishop exchanged it's not not the
end of the world but it's a bit it's not
not optimal yeah yeah I know you
shouldn't the exchange so much if you
have the isolated Queens pawn but
frankly speaking there's not much else
that that black can do but it's still a
position that that is very solid for
black I am I really shouldn't lose the
game it's only very uninspiring
admittedly
forum yeah what not so sure what this
move is doing
seem threatening anything special Queen
to Queen to a7 I don't know
hmm 27 looks annoying really what do I
play on that s six maybe have six
hmm so just just take it yeah well as
mentioned it not it's not much fun but
tough to break down
check
hmm we should be 5 20 plane Queenie too
okay so we got the bishops exchanged as
well
then the Queen and a queen end game I
don't think this pawn should be an
important important factor in fact I
wonder community for why not clingy fall
I should be able to go to sea for if he
takes and looks rather active I have a
slightly more active position here it's
not shouldn't do something great but the
queen is good only find I don't think
you can trade he trades King d4c for
King d 5c four looks bad so it cannot
exchange and i have i have moves to
improve the position a fire for whatever
and maybe i'll just threatening to enter
with the Queen Queen g2 oh yeah Quincy
to maybe just picking up song yes of
course you can can maybe play Quincy
five and force a draw but that's it
check
can I try to win noice this completely
insane I don't know probably it is
trying to go to be a door something on
the Queen move
I could have just taken a for at least I
should have thought about it and now now
we can play Queen B 5 again with with
the draw are those isolated Queen
compositions in the French are not so
easy to beat um they what and now I'll
take it I mean
Queen Quincy for just be five why not
activate the porn first it doesn't have
a good square for the Queen
before I can actually take even this is
not so great but I can go here yeah this
is okay check check check check check
ting a boy and game should be easy only
thing to watch out for is his stalemate
nostale matrix please check check check
hmm ok ok check me yeah well winning
those end Games's is a bit much but it's
this this kind of position here it's not
so terrible yes weaken yourself a bit
with their forward it's very often it's
not not such a big deal to hold it of
course it's not attractive to play but
it's not not a problem ok gtb I got some
was callous here I could have taken a
fall ready I mean he can take the five
but it's probably so the best the best
move but if I've just just blend us the
game and I think after that it's just an
extra ponent he doesn't have any counter
player or anything just winning Cromley
yeah oh thanks for watching